bien souvent on n'a pas bougé les
manifestants sont venus et qui souffre
maintenant les blessés
mais plus ils ont transporté des deux
côtés c'est une scène plutôt inédite en
les gardiens de la paix de paris
décembre dans la rue tracts à la main
pour tenter de renouer le dialogue avec
des manifestants depuis mai 68 les
rapports entre population et forces de
l'ordre sont tendues la poussée de
fièvre a surpris par son ampleur et le
degré de sa violence une violence qu'on
n'avait pas connu ici depuis longtemps
[Musique]
même après mai 68 les manifestations ont
continué manifestations sociales
manifestations de lycéens ou d'étudiants
souvent très politisée le gouvernement
tente de contenir les débordements en
instaurant la loi anti-casseurs en 1970
je pense j'espère que sa véritable
efficacité sera une efficacité de
dissuasion
car quand pour paraphraser le mot du
premier ministre les casseurs auront
compris qu'ils risquaient d'être le
payeur il résume nous lançons à être les
casseurs c'est le bien que je le reçois
mais cette loi n'a pas dissuadé bien au
contraire les rapports entre forces de
l'ordre et manifestants sont électriques
un lycéen est emprisonné car suspectés
d'avoir lancé des projectiles sur les
forces de l'ordre
un jeune instituteur père un oeil lors
de cette même manifestation
et c'est au lendemain de ces
affrontements qu'un syndicat de police
prend donc une initiative de descendre
dans la rue pour expliquer son travail
mais chaque partie campe sur ses
positions
certains manifestants portent même un
masque avec un oeil crevé afin de
dénoncer les violences policières et
vous en faites une page comme c'est ce
que vous avez vu le brigadier avec un
ayant droit
non mais vous devenus les gardiens de la
paix distribueront en tout 450 mille
tracts cette pause de réflexion comme il
l'avait appelé a même permis de voir
émerger une solution poétique à ces deux
villes
djamen defla vous avez un bâton dans la
main qu est ce qu on fait avec votre
bâton d'un poème c'est encore bien des
conflits je pense pas de là encore
jamais réussi et labeyrie à lens
puisqu'elle empêche la violence d'une
bonne idée d'ailleurs
[Musique]